good night
good evening ladies and gentlemen
members of the council welcome to this
evening's Southeast area planning
committee which is the last one of this
Council the next one will be a
completely different set of members so
agenda item while enchantment notices
uh recording of the meeting please note
the council will be recording and
Publishing on the council's website any
part of this meeting held in Open
Session
and fire in the event of a fire officers
will notify those present as if we
didn't already know please use the fire
exits marked with the green running man
which is the door you just came in by
the fire assembly point is Barclays Bank
car park which is across the road please
gather there and await further
instruction the gender item 2 apologies
for absence
the only one I have is cancel the bill
thank you very much
uh gender is in three minutes of the
last meeting to be found on pages
seven to ten to confirm the minutes of
the meeting of the committee held on the
15th of March of this year
members agree all that everybody happy
thank you thank you very much
agenda item four
disclosure of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded that
they are also require to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting and well I'm speaking I will
just say for agenda item five I do know
the applicant and the agent I don't
believe it's prejudicial in any form any
other members count of Luca
agent
um
cancer
right nobody else will move on to
gender item five
loftman's Farm Morden Road steeple the
construction of a two-story detached
rural workers dwelling change of land
use to C3
there's a recommendation to refuse for
the reasons as detailed in Section 8 of
this report
but it is before this committee as its
member call infant councilors Mrs
Channel and MW Helm
um
we need the rest of that
right who is presenting this one right
Mr Marsh Mr Marsh please
thank you
for whatever reason just um
[Music]
good
so this is an application for the
construction of a two-story detached
rural workers dwelling and the change of
views of the land from uh sewage
generous uses kennels to C3 residential
and the sign is outlined in the bed
actually here on this plan
the next plan shows the application site
for red as usual and then the wider land
holding which is the area of land used
for the alpaca operation is identified
within the blue line here and you've got
the addicts that are referred to in the
report that you can see these are the
existing kennel buildings which are
proposed to be demolished so you can see
there's sort of a group of four
with this larger group attendance main
parts of the site
the dwellings are certainly of no
architectural areas in predominantly
single store as you can see and as
explained in the report there has been a
building condition survey provided as
part of the application which concludes
that they are not um viable for to bring
it back into use as chemist
so this is the proposed site plan for
the new dwelling you can see that it's
positioned here with the um The Veranda
to the front and parking for three
dwellings of fun to get access to off
this road here which is like a crescent
which you can see the minute that comes
off from the May Golden Road and you've
got the existing camera buildings out by
the degree which are all proposed to be
demolished with their main buildings
outside the site boundary of course
being retained and you've got the
lockerman's farm Bungalow which is
within the blue line just serves in the
West
so this is the proposed design tour
plans and elevations for the new
dwelling conventional two-story form
with a pitched roof and uh that's the
proposed fishing materials are
composite planning and a plateau roof
and the arrangement is for a master
bedroom on the ground floor and then a
large Lounge dining area
and then on the first floor there are
two bedrooms with a bathroom and a large
office TV room which as certainly report
has the potential to be used as a
dwelling as a dwelling as a bedroom so
um so this is the Ethereal shot showing
the location within the Continental
position of this sort of red pin that's
on the Google Earth
image so you can just see the white
Crews of the buildings on the side here
which I've zoomed in on this slide to be
caught them all in a row running along
sort of Northwestern corner and then
this is the site you where my mouse is
where we've been building so proposed to
be demolished and that's the room too
early earlier and then we've got um the
willow Cottage here which is the
existing dwelling that's access on that
clinic Road and then you can see here
quite clearly the outside of the
paddocks
on there at the time
so this is just a couple of views from
the Morgan Road she's at any uh West
back towards Mayland and you've got the
access coming off here to the site
behind those trees and then that's from
the opposite direction looking East and
that's the other access and the other
end of that short Loop Road and then
this is um the 209 refer to Willow
cottage which is uh access off that road
as you approach into the site
this is a
a trading shop that's been provided
facing up up on the site so you can see
quite clearly then the extent of the
site that's covered with the cabin
buildings that are going to be removed
and then the arrangements I've been
referring to earlier on
so just a few photographs of the of the
site and it's setting again that's um
earlier if you come in and then enter
the site and find where the photograph
was taken then this slightly further in
on that road looking back out you've got
where I Cottage again and then the
carport and lufkin's abundantly there
a good idea of the current state of the
site and the position in which the
photographs are taken can be ascertain
from this plan here so on the Northern
Edge you've got these single story
building which is within the site which
would be demolished and then looking
across to that building there which is
outside the site which is in commercial
use and then that's looking back the
other way as you can see the Bungalow
and then the road that I've been
referring to is goes out in that
direction and then there's just a shot
from within the site
some more photographs within the site
itself or the sort of Central Area here
which is on that these two photographs
and they're moving slightly further
south you've got these Timber buildings
that are of the some Natures of these
buildings here
and again that's going further south to
come back on those buildings so you can
look back into the site and then that
again is a useful reference point
um looking out onto the
earlier
and then that's just looking slightly
further in the other direction
a couple of further photographs of the
sites closer to the side entrance
photograph 10 there's people sort of
down that side of his drawings that are
going to be demolished and then
photographs some keys up on the Side
Access Road looking back down in
got just four photographs here to give
you an idea of the current state of the
of the buildings from the inside
now this are some photographs of the
palate around the application site which
you'll recall on within the applicant's
control again as a male pack is there so
the top two are looking to the East and
the bottom two are looking to the South
I've just brought this slide up as a
reminder to you as I just talked and
screwed up the key issues to be
considered
fundamentally the starting point really
is the previous application which was
fried identical design and location for
the dwelling uh the only difference
being that this time the applicant has
provided supporting information to
justify The Proposal as a rural workers
dwelling
unfortunately for the reason set out and
Report the reason that has not been
overcome and I'll just briefly outline
and summarize with those issues to you
let's set out in the report because you
can break them down into issues of
vacation the most employment and
character in terms of location is
outside any second pound group and I
know News Detroit is very supported if
they are or an essential worker
um
and then
in terms of need the applicant has
provided financial information in a
letter from West Point Farm vet and a
letter from the director of the alpaca
society which do help his case at our
more sufficient to demonstrate we need
to have a full-time work on the site
importantly there is an existing
development of the file that no
information has been supplied and why
this would not be a suitable alternative
dwelling
the current business doesn't appear to
be viable there's no business plan to
illustrate possible future growth
the size and nature of the dwelling is
not commensured with the needs identify
as concern and this last point is an
important one the applicant intend to
expand the ability to reside on site
would enable the stock to expand 300
over the next three or four years but
crucially quality 87 requires that we're
onsite accommodation is essential
permission will only be granted in the
first instance for a temporary structure
which can easily be removed within three
years of the date of planting
so the members words are accepted for
the need for this running has been
demonstrated then the position should be
one of a refusal of this application and
invitation to submit an application for
a temporary structure and Accords for
that policy
in terms of the loss of employment use
as I mentioned earlier building to
survey report has been provided by their
food but this is not sufficient to
justify the dose of the employment site
itself and meet the necessary
requirements of global policy E1
and in terms of character there's no
difference to the character of
disability exactly the same so they have
addressed that element of the reason to
refuse on and then there's other two
reasons for refusal the first one is the
guy that comes from the provision of an
ecological report and the third reason
Cameron Denver comes through the
provision about the natural undertaking
I am aware that the agent has submitted
it and circulated an email to them just
seeking to robot the key points made in
the report I would just like to come
back on those in summary
irrespective of the position with the
five-year housing ban Supply
relative proximately to mail it is
people there are no public footpaths or
payments leading from the site into the
settlements and the only route is a busy
60 mile an hour road with thin grass
burgers and no street lights
in terms of the loss of employment use
cycle to summarize that but I've refer
members before they've entered their
decision to paragraph
5.15 of Murray talk which goes through
that
so in terms of the universities
I think is
um submitted that they give that
conversation between a call so overcome
that that reason so you would just be
left with one main reason for accuser as
set out uh it is recommended for refusal
thank you chairman
okay thank you
we have the size of aware only one
speaker tonight and that's missed Tony
cousin who's agent for the applicant
cousin if I step forward and find a
microphone you know the rules you have
two minutes to make your case from the
time the clock appears we've got one
yeah sorry just before we do that um Tim
would have to I think I'm not quite sure
the setup here but remove his uh
presentation so we can get the clock
Sean are we able to get the clock
[Music]
yeah you may need to um
you may need to close down your your
visuals
no I said you may need to just close
down your visuals
just uh I'm not sure where the clock is
good
sorry I'm not sure
yeah the um
please
yeah that would be one second
remote
oh there we go
all right Mr cousin two minutes uh let
me just find where the cursor is just so
I can go there okay
[Applause]
but you will recall hopefully that this
has been before you before and there was
a lot of
um or there appeared to be a lot of
support for the previous scheme but
members were concerned about an
agricultural employing this property to
hold you so this will enable you to do
that should you be mining to Grant
planning approval
um and all of that is done on the back
of the advice of the planning sort of
time
um yeah because it has provided to
record support information by way of um
the farm Enterprise business accounts
sustainable business plan going forward
expert with your statements from the vet
the alpaca is referred uh alpaca
breeders Society an ecology survey Aid
contamination survey instructional
surveyors server buildings a side Brands
agreement was something really
application so I'm surprised that that's
given us a refuses
The Proposal will not really cause the
loss of people on site members this only
ever people like one person which was
the evidence mother that news sees 13
years ago and if the farm holding was to
be able to to expand it's likely to
provide more employment opportunities
opportunities than the dog kennels ever
ever would or likely to in the future
um
regarding the character the applicant
Still Remains a losses had a character
from the accurate it says to our
knowledge is not a planning officer
that's ever visited the sideshow
culturally will take a sense of
consideration
thank you
oh the timing board members
council Mrs
channels chairman members I don't know
if you realize that farming is the
biggest industry in the world
probably is now entering into
diversification if you're profitable
this is an application for a farm not
working farm
and if they want to expand especially
with animals they need to be on site
they need to be there to care for the
animals anything can happen in the
middle of the night
or come from a farm and bread card so I
know all about this sort of thing and I
will pose against the opposite
recommendation to approve this so I
think
sustainable growth assessment boundaries
and Countryside D1 design quality field
Environmental
phase seven agricultural essential
workers
of accommodation and E4 agricultural
rural diversification because without
this dwelling you can't expand it needs
to be on the site so regard for these
animals
now obviously uh
unique to this area and that's just one
thing we should improve this I look
forward to someone's second in my
proposal is that Julie seconded
yes against cancer thank you
all right Council Mr China
well chairman um I'm going to make some
points here I think it's a Pity and it
is criticism it was actually a rather
significant
ly put forward to this Authority with
this application which is both a
designer access but applying these
statement
and I suppose I'm reading that and
studying that why I consider that it's
about come up with the policy refusals
they have done and I think there's some
certain points here
the dog kennels actually cover quite
significant area now there's some very
good photographs supplied with that um
statement I'm just referring to and I
would like to know if an officer has
visited the site by the way because I'm
a working first time around there wasn't
so I would like to know if an officer
did go and visit the site and I think
what's important to me and I know we've
heard about the studio NS use and that
the dog kennels and we're talking about
lost and employment site
well the buildings within a survey
report totally in total State Decay I
mean it would require significant
financial investment in fact I don't
think anybody could be brought back into
use
the point is to me that same to a degree
Brownfield land but we're not talking
about the Virgin Farmland here and we're
certainly not talking about glasses keep
slipping down wanting to build on a vast
area of this Farm the farm holding
itself is significant
loffman's is about 13.6 Acres and we're
talking about
773.7 meters square to be demolished
if this proposal were to be agreed by
this committee
it would have significant immunity space
there's also car parking space is not
referred to in Liverpool
and actually the amount for this
proposal to occupy of the area of
existing buildings to be demolished so
if it was to be allowed it'd only be
22.5 percent
so I see that in to be a planning game
in terms of very ugly buildings that are
in a state of decay which we've seen
that person I've actually got photos
here on that planning statement showing
all the buildings in their form
so there'll be again that in mind my
estimation significant if you're going
to only occupy 22.5 percent
and also of course if you put that then
into the equation of what the
application site would be covering and
the report does detail that the proposed
value would only are occupied 7.24 of
the application site and the application
site only 3.92 of the land making
uplothians farm and yet we're hearing
this would have significant impact on
the countryside now we're not talking
about thank goodness you know four
dwellings coming or nine buildings
coming and we are talking about the
dwelling that is required because the
Alpaca Farm so can I described on that
um in in terms of the officer saying
we're not sure the success of it but
clearly the applicant wants to um well
he's doing diversification under the
farmers Council housate but increase
that and which I've read the reports
from both the vet and the other person
backing this up and it would make sense
uh I forget that what the business of
this is going plan on something but how
it explains how actually this is sort of
important to have someone on site
when I look at the photographs that are
being supplied with that statement and
I'm doing a visualization of that
dwelling I can see to me significant
visual impacts the start kennels if
we're talking about them have been out
of use for about 12 years if they were
to come back and we're saying that's the
use of the employment what
car Journeys then what about noise and
everything here we would have someone on
site to introduce actually that person
coming to do other various aspects in
terms of requirements of the family but
also for the other business use nearby
so I could see the benefits of cutting
down motor vehicle Journeys not adding
to the equation and I'll close it 13 and
that's another point but I don't quite
pick them up on myself with Dr
sandwriting but I just do make those
points
um I can see when the officers home and
in a few live on the evidence and
everything but for me I feel there is a
certain amount of openness protected but
I'm looking at the bigger picture in
terms of what I see a plan and get I'm
not going to give them no Debra Johnson
to tell me where I'm wrong but if I see
Dreadful buildings being demolished
which I see on Brown land see the
dwelling coming and it well and it takes
up while less use of that site and the
whole outside site the whole
establishment the phone to me I see that
as a plan again
sorry Kansas caves
uh I'm not feeling too many in my ears
is uh one of the officers statements
that if we do approve this then we
really should
approve temporary accommodation and
indeed one of the concerns I have about
Social Development like this is how do
we know in the future that this will not
just become a private house in a private
area so
um whereas if you if you go with the
with the suggestion that we have proved
that there's the applicant will be
applies with a temporary dwelling then
we then that's a demonstration of their
commitment to uh to the business of
farming and now I don't know the
applicant's crossing so and I don't mean
to cast any aspersion so but we have to
take a general view of what is possible
and so there is a danger that if we
allow such developments um we're setting
presidents that may be a problem
okay
you have numbers
and perhaps the officer
um
I believe is in the case officer is in
your site
Mr Marsh can you help
[Music]
Ed away
Michael units
um I haven't visited the site but
officers
um officers
no but I I don't normally visit the site
myself yeah
but
officers Miss Sadler
and Miss herner had visited the site
now visiting the site doesn't
necessarily mean that Dave
this is that they they the owners of the
site
there's one that put the yellow sign up
and I think
somebody else
engagement yeah
so I mean that was the previous idea I'm
really out and confused about it yeah
that was a previous application well I
mean what what poses me about this is
22. what puzzles me about this is if an
officer hasn't visited the site and I
mean visited it they have no idea what
the existing buildings on that site are
like but they cannot find that out from
standing outside and peering in the
driveway
so
I think
the spirit emphasis on the side business
it's a bit sort of misguided because
there's plenty of information available
on the stage
in my presentation so you can see that
we almost gonna happen did you
acknowledge that they are and at all
states by the buildings today
material
definitely Austin didn't do side down to
a month so it's not an essential
requirement but in this case there's
sufficient information available there's
nothing that is hidden by not doing a
site visit you wouldn't be able to to
ascertain you want to make a decision
and I think if you're going to talk
about lots of character in particular
location then you need to go there I
mean you need to go there and you need
to see it and I actually visited this
site on what I saw the greatest respect
um it's Southern
um try not to use the word Galaxy
um
and then then my attention went to the
local Parish Council
one of my questions
is that the the office side
has referred to
a five-year housing and supply
can ask you a question through your
Channel
does the council have a five-year house
advice right
Mr Marsh
if you can answer a Tim if not I'll
answer it
[Music]
yeah
given the location of the nature of the
application as a as a dwelling or an
essential worker you know unsustainable
location the the important and I'm
religious politicizes and having heard
the various members have made you need
to make your decision in accordance with
the development plan and the policies
that apply are quite clearly East H7 and
E1 and I set that out in the report that
the applicant is not demonstrated
provide solution information to enable
you to make a decision
but there is an essential need the way
forward as I said in my presentation you
think members consider there to be
is not to Grant consent for this large
dwelling that's not commensurate to the
to the size of the operation but to to
refuse the application and United an
application for Assembly Building in a
forms with the requirements of the
policy
John I'm really really confused I
understand what the officers are saying
about the final ViewHouse
it doesn't give much weight but
nevertheless it falls past of this
um
made an announcement for Council saying
that council did have a final
there was that announcement that
announcement was made to officers but I
think members are quite clear that that
announcement is a point in time it is
not the official figure it is not it is
not the figure it's not the figure which
has been robustly checked and mostly
informed part of the annual monetary
report as normally would be the case so
can you let me come back so we've got a
director of modern District Council
presenting a figure of 5.1 years and yet
Mr Johnson saying it's got to be checked
he would have announced he would have
announced 5.1 unless it being checked
until I fear we're going off on the
tangent this would be certainly be
something I'll take out with missing
dogs something is clearly not life
development management you know it can
be so much easier Mr Johnson if there'd
been a members update published after
the 30th of March because I know a lot
of developers National house builders
are very much interested in that
statute of mouse
I do I do need to come back on this
because that was uh I mean members are
fully aware of the circumstances in
which that announcement was made yeah
that announcement was fully caveat in
terms of that does not form the official
uh uh uh five-year housing land Supply
figure which still is at 3.66 and that's
clearly the case our members are members
are fully aware of the caveatic position
well I've listened to the tape several
times and
and I'm thinking
with local authority to announce that
figure unless they're absolutely sure
and I honestly think that they should I
do need to come back on this because
that is the published figure that is the
figure that is still within on the
website that you know that these figures
are published yearly yeah the yearly
figure is still 3.66 that has not been
superseded by the updated report and I'm
sure the owner of a member is quite
clearly aware of that I don't know why
we've announced 5.1 but as I said
um
I think I think what we've
I mean the relevance of this obviously
has to be that as of this meeting's time
we're looking at 3.66 years housing land
supplies and the answer is no we don't
have a five-year housing land Supply and
that's the only way we can look at it
from what Mr Johnson tells us
I have no idea
what is
the subject of the particular matter the
report has been written in the way in
which we normally write reports when
there is a dwellings proposed there is a
dwelling proposed here and it's proposed
on what is the established and the
official published figure and that is
clearly the position there is not a
five-year Rising right um as Mr Marsh
has put out we are diverting the phone
topic and what we do need to focus on is
the policies and it does seem to me and
I'll have to use what seems to be pretty
colloquial here is that
maybe it can be argued as material
considerations but clearly the reasons
are given for justification of this
application are not based on the policy
thank you chairman right other members
councilman
Council misspelled
overnight so you know the fact that
somebody is needed to be there is
something
important
thank you councilman thank you thank you
chairman last time this came to
committee I don't remember the advice
given to us as members that we should
refer it back because we did refer it
back to have a temporary scripture No
the reason was that the previous
application was for what's known as a
marketable dwelling not not as for an
Agricultural workers
I remember that there was a really long
discussion that was we've talked about
how suggestions that was made to
actually help the applicant and we as a
committee suggested the applicant drive
back and discuss it with the planning
officer now I can't remember which
planning officer it was to forgive me
we've had a bit of a change around
chairman
um but I think to now turn around and
have a reporters that's probably correct
Mr Marshall's most probably a star model
have experience than the rest of us put
together in planning but then to turn
around and change it yet again to say
you've now got to change it to have a
temporary structure whereas before that
wasn't any advice that was given so all
I'm saying is I think it's saying it
says to be a little
um unfair and a bit mean in my my book's
German I mean I'm more than happy to
support it to go for the animal safety
and also for the temporary structure I
don't yeah forgively Mr Marshall I would
have never met in person but I don't
think I agree with the officer on this
occasion
a few points
also point it's about demolishing some
very significant decayed buildings and a
large area and this drilling for
agricultural person could come up over
far less
um here so I have some difficulty say
about the visual impact if I'm Frank
because to me that would look far better
and I've highlighted what the planning
statement I can see no reference in the
middle of the report to that Commander
statement which I felt was very very
detailed and gave me something to design
and access things and by the agent and
the planning statement we're a great
deal of detail on my computer if anyone
would like to have a look or you can't
find it if you go look at the
applications
what I would say is leaving me also I'm
we always heard from an officer very
respected officer I have to say she's no
longer The Authority always said said
also you have to consider things in the
past planning history and we've had
other appeal statements quoted to us
this Authority or this committee
actually allowed only a practical the
planning statement planned at Rivers
League this committee there was an
officer refusal and this committee gave
commission to a drilling on that site
and indeed those also business
um
also not far from this site in Maryland
it was an inspector okay it's not
exactly like the like there was a farm a
head of arm went over onto the
residential conversion to a team with a
reverse line here we refused it as an
authority with the arguments and not
sustainable transport goodness knows
what else the inspector came along and
approved sorry allowed that to be on so
we lost that one also I would have to
say recently it wasn't a Mortimer which
an officer did highlight members enough
to go against the policy again not like
for like but wouldn't mortemer the
little nice golf compatible whatever you
want to call it 18 dwellings permitted a
lot of employment site that the evidence
or whatever the opposite said the
committee disagreed and said that about
18 houses should be allowed when
previously there'd been two previous
applications residential reviews so I'm
actually looking at some of the things
that were going on which we're also can
be utilized and that is why I have a
degree of sympathies with this
application and I feel the points I made
about it not to be detrimental to the
officer's recommendation I think I
acknowledge that I could see that the
office was coming from but to me I see a
planning game you're not talking about
free games coming there are some
Journeys around there I think there were
four four dwellings nearby nearby we're
talking about significant demolition of
some very very decayed useless built on
a Sci-Fi signal for the Africans
could actually support the statement
does refer to decades and I think
actually the surveyor made that and so
to me I see a planning game betterment
in terms of allowing that dwelling here
and so and I've highlighted the
percentages which were found in the
state within the agent highlighted in
percentage terms what you've demolished
and what you get back
what you're getting back takes up far
less than those demolished buildings do
and if you look at the whole holding of
the farm in itself the percentages are
very very low channel so that's what
I've handed on and I am actually
disappointed that their reference or any
detail from that planning statement was
perhaps confined within the report
before moments tonight
but anybody else got anything to add if
not there is a proposal by councilor
Helm duly seconded by council Mrs
channel to approve the officer to
approve the recommendation against
officer recommendation
like those in favor of approval please
show
Helm
council Mrs Channel
customer system it's all right I'm there
the Council of this belt
and
um
any any against
cancer schemes and there's two of us
that are extensions
so yeah I think there's more to be said
in favor of approval than um
than there is of refusal especially
considering a
an inspected decision not a million
miles away from you in which he
recommended the demolition of a bill of
a Farm building and a replacement with a
dwelling house and
so and there's several about
it again
um
and it was an attitude that came back I
couldn't deal with it so I'm just
weighing up a number of remembrance it's
no just back to the planning office I
think it was a very good report that the
officer presented which I could be
careful they say which was nice
conditions that we probably should have
dealt with the first but I assumed just
standard conditions with the
agricultural conditions oh yes
the
employment's agreement had been
satisfied according to this report it
has not been and again it has been
expected to see
um
we'll give some information I think that
there was a draft agreement actually
submitted at the first application
statement actually made clear that in
that plan to take John referred to well
what I would say with that is that the
the session 106 would normally go
through the process of checking uh
subject to it being satisfactory that's
when the decision notice would be issued
so we're subject to that satisfactory
check-in process
it's approved
all right moving on a gender item six
any other items a business the chairman
the committee decides are Urgent I only
have one and it's a fairly minor one but
it isn't it's very important one good
luck to all those of you who are
standing in the gain in May and uh
for those of us who are not
well I hope we can find something to do
with our time
we can always turn up and have a look
can't we
we might do that
um
[Laughter]
always
um
right well thank you officers for all
your time and effort over the last four
years
and um I will close this final meeting
of this for you yeah
[Music]